[Música]
así que después de un área donde una vez
por qué
[Música]
e
y entonces
y siempre siempre
más bien que por estadística
la señora va a ser la que más fácilmente
se está volviendo normal está
acostumbrada eso después del tiempo
menor de 15 años de 20 años de 40 años
hombre-mujer
un abrazo
siempre
en general
[Música]
por esto
puede
ah
[Música]
de mis ojos
a la espera de la presentación a bordo
negrito disfruto imposible
y hasta dónde podemos llegar
recuerda esto
recientemente preparando esta charla de
tiburón
porque la gente es muy divertido sin
embargo la película de la edición que
tenemos nosotros de los tiburones a
partir de esta película la gente comenzó
a ver mucho más libros como éste animal
tipo cazador malvados poner gente de los
perdidos
cuando ves así al año
pero a partir de la película y hasta el
día de hoy
y la población del título partido ha
bajado en un sentido
el título blanco
la bajada
y yo les digo pero esta gente no
entiende la referencia
el tema de difusión que en realidad y se
deja afectar para atención condición
puede ser muy peligrosa por eso hay que
tomar en cuenta esto
que consiste en pasar lo mismo
y tenemos claro es puede ser peligrosa
puede ser violento puede dar miedo pero
nunca va a dejar de ficción para
entender que nos hace reír porque
invitaba positivo es las señoras y los
señores que yo digo un chiste todo el
tema de religión o de sexo y del casal
y si se pasa
y se tapan se cubren como que se
protegen a los estudiantes como sí
y no se puede meter
[Música]
como esa
les cuento esto porque a partir de este
cuestionamiento de qué tan fuerte puede
hacer un informe dedicado un poco
terminada
para la invitación con risa
para poder tener el poder de esta
ficción pero es sorpresa el humor
porque si es que puro esperado
y te cumple lo que esperas no te va a
dar si yo te empieza a contar un chiste
o una historia cómica tú sabes cómo se
va a acabar es muy poco probable que te
ríes
todo lo que necesita de sorprendente
sorprendente con eso existe para poder
reír en títulos de la realidad no te vas
y el destino
tiene un poco que ver también con la
poesía
como
como de ángeles del lado opuesto
[Música]
acerca del poema
y quienes bailaban siento vuelva a salir
a explorar
de alguna manera
un chiste causa algo similares
el chiste existe que nos recuerda algo
que teníamos
de mí
cuando yo
si no todos
pero una cosa que va siendo por alguien
del camino del mundo
por qué
pero bien la sorpresa del entendimiento
va a funcionar si es que nosotros no
entendemos
y para que podamos entender el sistema
que nos conecte con
por ejemplo si es que yo aquí en esta
sala cuando existe se aprobó a que me da
un montón de material
ustedes se van a reír
porque sí
[Música]
porque tengo tiempo
[Aplausos]
y el público
y por ejemplo redes sociales
caliente
y esto es con
[Música]
y es lo que tenemos que buscar entonces
consistorio con un pingüino
[Música]
y
y prueba
y con ello el equipo
era un crédito que hacía
porque tú tienes que empezar
una vez un poquito de la vida
una vez esté solo esta conciencia social
de que voy a adaptar
porque pueden ayudar
y comenzamos a entender el modo como un
espacio de justificación para cualquier
cosa
es nueva
ahora
a sacar la información el material para
hacer un chiste de la realidad
pero es una ficción y el chiste es un
chiste novela como la mitad está hecha
[Música]
lo mismo pasa con el chile
queremos que queremos
pero no es la realidad por más doloroso
yo puedo decir ahorita
no
porque son palabras yo no puedo cambiar
esa realidad
entonces pensar que un chiste va a
cambiar la realidad que va a cambiar
nuestro día a día realmente
no tiene mucha relación con la realidad
es como jugar como un bebé y decirle
tengo dólares y que el bebé si fuera
humano
eso no pasa en la vida real
porque nosotros sin embargo sin embargo
sin embargo no voy a ver qué puede haber
violentos xenofóbicos pero por qué
existen esos chistes porque estábamos
ninguna realidad afectiva sino cómica
violenta machista homofóbica con un
montón de cosas negativas
entonces como
[Música]
normalmente sí pero tú no puedes echarle
la culpa por hacer un chiste
porque la gente cree me censurado
comedia la comedia
[Música]
y sin embargo
este se basa en una idea falsa
en un estereotipo falso de la mujer
que no tiene ninguna gente en este mundo
que todavía cree que esto es gracioso
porque todavía se siente identificado
entonces
esa sociedad
ahí está el problema la gente que se ríe
de su bebé está respondiendo una
sociedad violenta
y es que vaya más allá que pueda
enganchar cosas que siguen fomentando la
violencia eso sí existe puede comentar
pueden legitimizar posibles
comportamientos así
pero sin embargo eso no lo hace que
quiere ejercer una adicción
entonces cuando esta censura a la
comedia
porque algún día nuestra parte
la comedia lo que hace es responder a
una sociedad que es agresiva
la causa no el síntoma y curar la gripe
no los mocos
entonces
[Música]
pero
y si es que no molesta
está bien
el punto es
por media
en silencio
yo
eso es lo que más
porque sí
[Música]
entrevistas entraron para matar a los
dibujantes
puede pasar con un licuado
por hacer bromas
sobre gente con mucho poder
y seguimos viviendo esta sociedad una
sociedad más justa
más violenta
y basauri
y eso es lo peor que nos puede pasar por
eso yo les digo
es que no les gustó no existe
no también
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]